hello everybody my name is marklar
welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's
Fazbear nights I am finally back from an
extended
vacation in the world of purgatory where
I have not been able to do absolutely
anything for a very long time except
work on the things that you already know
about which I'm not going to get into
too many details about but I will talk
about a little bit but if you're
watching this from the future hi welcome
hello everybody hi welcome welcome come
on in come on in come on in come on in
hello hi we're going to be playing
through Fazbear nights which if you
remember I played it about God about a
month ago now um it's a free roam Five
Nights at Freddy's game it was pretty
fun it was really interesting and I
think it offers me a nice balance of uh
time to talk and also time to panic so
I'm going to be there yes it's me I'm
back yeah I know
hello hello it's that guy who played
slender it's me how I be doing I be
doing good i' be doing good because I
finally got a little bit of a day off
just yesterday I was traveling like
crazy last week I was all over the place
I was bouncing between a whole bunch of
different spots um but I'm finally back
and I am getting into this and normal
videos once
more how's the movie going so far I mean
if you saw the trailer you probably know
how it's going which is wow it just
requires a lot of work I had to Sprint
ahead to get um like it farther than I
intended which meant that I had to work
pretty much basically like 14 16 hour
days just nothing but editing you like
the new trailer thank you very much I
hope you enjoyed it it was a fun one to
make when is the next trailer I just put
out one trailer you can't enjoy a little
bit let it soak in a little bit you
can't let it soak just a little bit and
you're already like oh where's the the
next trailer yeah anyway what I'm doing
today is I'm catching you up on a lot of
different things I'm not just going to
talk about my movie I'm going to talk
about another movie that some of you may
have been asking about for a while now
and uh I I intend to provide some
answers about that but I am going to
wait until a few more people are here
before I get into it um and know this
isn't just one of those stalling things
I actually intend to tell you straight
up so that you know and it can inform
your decision but before I do that we're
going to let more people get in here and
you're going to tell me cuz I got a new
audio setup again and you're going to
tell me if this is good so is my voice
coming in
clean is that too
loud that is that too
[Music]
loud am I feeling better I feel fine was
I not feeling good okay it's good
everything's good everything's all good
sounds perfect my voice is good levels
are balanced I'm actually a professional
streamer I know everything that I'm
doing okay too quiet turn up your volume
then I can't help you there everything
needs to be louder you have a volume
knob I don't want to set if everything's
balanced then that's what's good and I'm
going to keep it like that if everything
everything's good I'm not going to touch
it because as soon as I get into it
suddenly there's going to be louder
noises and I'm going to die and
everyone's going to be mad cuz their
ears have exploded and I'm not going to
be able to do
anything
all right I forgot the sensitivity of
this game was way too high um there we
go forget if Lumen does anything so if
you remember this one I think I've
continued so it should be a bit more
aggressive a bit sooner but I still
intend to die a whole lot well I don't
intend to but I just imagine it's going
to happen hi foxy how you
doing I don't remember the layout I had
just started to get into the layout
before it is also very is it is it just
me or is it extremely dark oh here we go
can I get a little more just a little
more well
that's I guess that's a little better uh
I'll take it okay so I know I can't be
wandering around but I think I'm going
to die pretty quick here so I'm not
exactly going to try to stret about it I
mean nope I don't even remember where
the security office is
yeah is this better this is as bright
there there was no other option for this
is bright and brighter so I'm this is
the brightest maybe it's cuz of lumen
nope all
right it's fine don't worry about it
yeah your screen's so blurry I turn up
your quality setting I I don't know I
can't help you
there the
[__] oh here right who wait a minute
wait a
minute oh I forgot that they're going to
be active a lot earlier oh no wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait all right well
um well that went about as well as I
expected it
to I can't wait for a haircut my God
this goes right in my mouth every single
time so that was as bright as it gets
it's on brighter there's there's really
nothing else to do about it so let's try
that again and let's see if I can
actually get to the office this time
because I don't I don't think I did it
that time I could have sworn I went the
way that I went before but what do I
really know nothing
apparently this
goes this is how I I was supposed to
make a right before I go there because
this is going to go all the way around
to the office or at the very least I can
be kind of safe not a lot of safe but
kind of safe wonder if that saves any
power
okay so anyway yeah if it's a little
fuzzy turn up the quality of your stream
you can do that manually even if on
you're on mobile I think um but while
I'm here the one thing I
want I swear to God this light is
haunted I do not know why it'll turn
back on in three two
one it just turns off randomly and then
back on I have no idea I need to get
replaced but I just haven't had time
because it's the first time I got back
home um but one thing I wanted to talk
about other than all the other things
and and I'll probably talk about it in
more detail towards the end of the
stream um but I did want to talk about
the Five Nights at Freddy's movie I know
I've been very ambiguous about it I know
I've been very mysterious about it and
it's kind of been a thing where I was
hoping that there would have been like
some schedules aligning but I did want
to say straight up without any
qualification I am not going to be in
the five Nights at Freddy's movie and I
know that's crushing and I know that's
disappointing and I know there's a lot
of people that really were hoping that
would be the case but I wanted to say
unequivocally that unfortunately I'm
not and I'll explain
why and I'll explain
why I'll explain get actually everyone
freak out everyone freak out get your
freakouts out of the way so that we can
just just get it all out now just get it
all out now just go panic scream at the
top of your lungs just gush gush gosh
gosh
gosh come on it's okay why would you do
that oh [__] I might be
dead um look I will explain why and it
is not anything malicious it is not
anything being snubbed it is not
anything like that I don't want anyone
to think that it is simply a matter wait
let me let me make sure I'm not going to
die in an
instant oh freak oh
God I don't like that um let me just
close a door I I don't even know I don't
care all right so it's not anything like
that it was supposed to happen let's get
this straight it was supposed to happen
there
was uh like time that it was supposed to
occur and unfortunately and I saw this
coming a while away but
unfortunately the Five Nights at
Freddy's movie in my movie iron lung
were being filmed at the exact same time
and this was not like anything other
than it just so happened to be a
conflict to schedule now despite that I
was trying to make it work I was trying
to make it work because I was supposed
to be out there for two days and I was
supposed to film with them and I was
supposed to be in the movie but
unfortunately it was one of those things
where I needed every second that I had
to make my movie what it needed to be
and unfortunately even though the timing
was like maybe going to line up it was
one of those things where I had to make
a call because I wouldn't expect them to
compromise the quality of their project
for me and just in the same way I
wouldn't expect them to com me I
wouldn't hope I would hope that they
wouldn't expect me to compromise the
project of my movie for them so it was
one of those situations where the
schedule was there but it just didn't
line up like there was so many things
that I had to do and flying out to go
film for like a very short turnaround
come right back it was just like those
were two days that I couldn't afford to
lose and it was two days like if there
was no issues with like being away for
that long and traveling there could have
been another day that was there and it
was like I couldn't lose 2 days let
alone more to be able to do any of that
so
unfortunately I am not in the Five
Nights at Freddy's movie and I'm going
to die because I was not watching my
power so this is um this is just what I
deserve because um well I'm not going to
make it there yeah that's the thing
though that's the thing it was uh no it
wasn't a matter of pay it wasn't a
matter of pay at all there was I I I
don't think I wanted any pay it was just
not a thing that was like ever on my
mind about it I wanted to be in it it
was simply a matter of the schedules
didn't look and the reason that I was I
was trying to like be koi about it is
because I was hoping that there was
going to be a situation later on I'm
about to die there was going to be a
situation later on where it could
happen but given that the movie is
coming out and like oh my God oh my
God oh my God I've never seen that
before
uhoh well Freddy was not happy with
me um no I I can't talk about what I
would have done in the movie I can't
talk about any of that because it's
still obviously hasn't come out yet but
I did want to say that there's no
animosity between me and the crew or
Scott or anything like that everyone was
trying their best to make it work but it
just didn't it just didn't and the thing
is I had to prioritize my movie I had to
there was just all there was just so
much that had to be done in the time and
for iron lung to be what it needed to be
I had to dedicate everything into that
project and so unfortunately yeah I'm
not going to be in the five nightc at
Freddy's movie but that doesn't mean
that I don't support it that doesn't
mean that I don't I'm not cheering for
it but it's one of those things where
it's like I I mentioned this like way
back when when these conversations were
first happening like last about this
time last year I was telling them that
like hey this is really cool I would
love to make this work but I am filming
a project at this exact window and I
don't know and this is me putting words
in people's mouth I don't know if they
understood the level of production that
I was making like that's and I'm not
saying that they should have like how
dare they not know what I'm doing it's
one of those situations where how could
they because obviously I guess I am a
YouTuber what am I really doing but in
reality like I have a high expectation
for the projects that I make you guys
have seen me make space and all and
Heist and and the various other projects
that I do I pride myself in the quality
that they that I put into them but at
the same time it's like yeah I can't
expect them to really acknowledge what
that's going to be because in any other
circumstance it would be like yeah I
would bend over backward like anyone
would bend over backwards to be in our
movie but it's also just like I am I'm
making a movie too like that's just
it I'm making a movie too and if you
have seen the trailer for iron lung
which just dropped this weekend I highly
recommend you go see that as well you
will see that I am holding myself to a
very high standard of quality so yeah
it's uh it's one of those things where
just schedules didn't line up up and the
alternatives for making it work weren't
what I wanted them to be you know what I
mean it was just like the compromises
were too much of a compromise to make it
happen it was an excellent trailer thank
you thank you I know there was a lot of
people that who saw the iron Long
Trailer that was just being like oh man
it didn't tell me anything but here's
what I don't like I don't like trailers
that spoil everything I don't like
trailers that spoil the whole movie I
don't think that's a good way to Hype it
I think that's a good way to ruin
everything that you're trying to build
you spend all this time trying to craft
a narrative and trying to craft a story
and then you're just going to you're
going to put out a trailer that
basically shows the entire movie that's
uh where's oh that's not good where's he
going where'd he go oh god
oh where are they
I swore I I saw Bonnie approaching this
area did he go somewhere
else I don't like
that
what oh God oh God I don't like that
put okay sorry I'll connect that thought
in just a moment I have to concentrate a
little
bit okay I don't see anyone over
here I don't know oh oh oh my freaking
[__] what was
that oh
freak okay don't like that don't know
what that was about
um
what
what okay well until I get eyes on
Bonnie and Freddy I'm not really going
to just open the doors willy-nilly
I know that I'm wasting power I know
that but just bear with me guys
well
what oh hi
yeah I'm going to keep the doors closed
I'm going run out of power again but
whatever I don't like
that I don't like that at
all pull out the gun I wish I wish I had
it I wish I did
yeah I'm boned why I just keep
what
okay so this camera I'm just trying to
get orientation so now chica is going
that way that's
interesting foxy is still there you're
still there I could technically open the
door leading here probably oh my god oh
there's Bonnie okay well that's good
then if I open
this should be okay
for oh
God
oh
god oh my
god oh how much power oh shoot oh that's
not nearly oh no that's not nearly
enough time Andor power oh I go oh no oh
God maybe I'll make
it
my
God yeah what happens if I
run I can't see
[Music]
anything
anyway yeah uh so what was I saying I I
was saying um yeah so the trailer for
iron long if you haven't seen it go
check it out on my channel it's the last
thing that was uploaded um yeah I hate
trailers that spoil
everything so with this one it actually
does tell a lot it says a lot and it
definitely sets the tone for what iron
lung is going to be about and for those
of you who didn't know iron lung is
going to be in theaters so that will be
very
fun um and at the same
time should be a a wonderful experience
for everyone to
enjoy yes what is iron lung about I mean
if you play the game you probably have a
pretty good idea but ocean of blood
horrible nightmares okay okay here's
Bonnie at least Bonnie's always slow
slow yeah but but obviously the main
news being I was so busy working on iron
long that I could not make time to be in
the Five Nights at Freddy's movie and I
I'm like this is okay for me to say this
because uh Scott himself asked me to say
something to this effect just because
like wanted it to not be like a a mean
surprise if people were really expecting
it um to happen but yeah unfortunately
not going to be in the FNAF movie
unfortunately tried to make it work
schedules did not line
up see I don't know what's in the
camera see he zips so
fast and I don't know
why so right now I'm trying to just like
keep the doors open longer because
that's the only way that I'm going to be
able to make
it
n just nah
just not dealing with
that okay I don't see Freddy over
here so I don't know if that means I can
predict
his
approach I don't like the laughter
okay I'm doing better on power it really
is just having both of those
down is the
problem oh you like the trailer for iron
long oh thank you so much I was sitting
on that one for a
bit I was hoping to get that out sooner
but things are what they
are that [__] haunted
light
why he can't come from this way can
he that would be
mean that would be
sassy oh I shouldn't just keep that door
closed what else am I supposed to
do okay there's chica over there I don't
see where Freddy
is I don't I don't see where Freddy is
oh I don't like the
laughter iron lung blood fake no real we
went to
location we went to a real blood ocean
just you wait it's going to be
cool I don't like
that see I don't know cuz he got me in
the last video that I posted he got me
in the other door and he sprinted up
Lightning
Fast oh where was that okay God screw
you
man okay there's Bonnie he's still slow
oh there's
Freddy oh he was over there
okay that's good okay Freddy and Bonnie
whoa freak that but he well holy
crap am I out of power nine I might make
it you guys saw that
right I didn't he I thought he was
running the other way
oh go get
it oh
frick oh God all right I'm just going to
wait it out just going to wait it out
it's all good I'm playing
dead what
huh
o don't do
it don't do
it holy [__] all
right all right I
did right so that was night three
that was night three that was only night
three only night three God all
right yeah um by the way pretty sure and
I think the trailer you guys might
agree I'm pretty sure iron long is going
to set the world record for most fake
blood in a horror movie I'm just you
know I got a funny feeling I got a funny
feeling feeling that uh we might have
set the record for most blood in a
horror movie which would be pretty cool
I think that you would all agree that's
pretty
cool okay all
right yes is iron lung going to be
R-rated
um
yeah yeah yeah pretty much yeah yeah
what role am I playing uh the main
one what oh my god oh he's
quicker oh he's fast what are you doing
what you doing what are you
doing going this way don't do it oh
that's
Freddy I don't like this
uh yeah
so I'm still I know what Google says the
record for the most amount of blood at
50,000 gallons and I'm saying to you
straight up I aware of that number and I
still think we have the
record and our blood isn't red
water oh my God
so take that for what you
will on
that I look I I not only have the
numbers I have the math and I have
everything to back up the numbers that
we have
and also I still
think what was that what was that what
did I just
see oh no I'm so going to run out of
power okay I think I think that the time
of me you know just kind of
casually oh okay I don't know where
these cameras are well you're not
supposed to be
here see I'm not 100% sure where these
cameras are pointing
so if you're pointing this way then that
is the entrance towards my office right
or at least this
direction I'm I'm probably going to die
this one just bear with me and this is
pointing that way I wish these had
little like angles to show what they're
looking at but I think it's that way and
think that is towards my office and then
that must be this way is towards my
office so I'm probably okay to open for
the
moment for the
mom
okay fck quick oh God oh God oh God oh
God I you know this game I this one is
kind of
scary this one's kind of scary
what why what do you mean what are you
talking
about
what
what I don't know what that is
oh there's Freddy oh he ready to zoom
all right I'm just going to open this
for a
moment I don't know what that
was I'm doomed I'm running out of power
oh
freck I don't
know I don't
know I hate that
ah you can crank power in this game
how can
you I sacrific half of my subscribers
for the blood for the movie oh you
know people do it that would
be that would be a pretty fun promotion
I would love to do a blood
drive leading up to the release of the
movie and we try to
raise the amount of blood donated that
we used in the movie like the amount of
fake blood if you guys oh I'm
doomed freck I don't know how close I
was I don't think I was nearly close
enough but wouldn't that be cool if we
did like a nationwide blood drive and
tried to uh
rally the amount of blood that we used
in there so not
only
that' be pretty cool right that' be
pretty cool I haven't donated blood in a
bit so it's about time I did I always
did a double when I would donate blood I
I got my uh gallon pin so I've donated
uh a gallon of blood in my life um so I
could always do more I could always do
more all
right collecting blood for our
too
it's okay if you can't donate blood
that's fine but there there'll probably
be enough people that are able to donate
blood but wouldn't that be awesome you
go it's like right before the movie
shows you there's a there's a blood
donation truck outside you do that and
then you go in the movie and you pass
out mid theater and then I could I could
say like oh man my movie made so many
people pass out in the middle of the
showing it's it's that traumatizing yeah
that'd be pretty cool yeah that was also
this idea that we would do a showing
like you know a movie theater in a pool
like the premiere would be in a pool and
we would die the pool red and you would
have floaties and watch the movie like
that would be pretty cool I don't know
how that would happen but I just like
you know the members were kicking around
ideas and uh and some good ones amongst
all the detrice there's occasionally a
good idea in there most of the detri my
ideas but you know occasionally there's
a good
idea I don't know if turning off this
van helps but I feel like it does what
was that someone was say saying about
cranking power I don't even remember
that I have no
idea yeah I I can't say anything to
release State just yet I can't say
anything about International just yet
those are things that are far beyond my
part of view um those are conversations
that are in progress and you know I have
no idea um I once I have details I'm not
trying to be super secretive about it
it's like I literally don't know so I
can't say anything uh to it but once I
know details I will share them as much
as I can of what I am allowed to say but
pretty much because I'm in control of
everything I am allowed to say whatever
I want um and right now they're all
out
oh it's too
soon oh Freak
Me Oh
freak
Frick oh my
God what was that Freddy I couldn't even
see I wasn't looking directly at it I
only saw that in my
peripheral oh I don't know what that any
of that was I don't know any was oh so
for those are just joining that weren't
at the beginning of this I I'm not
joking about it I'm not like beinga
around the bush I am not going to be in
the Five Nights at Freddy's movie and no
this isn't just like a a ploy to be like
oh ho but actually I am unfortunately
I'm not and it is it is unfortunate
because I had every intention of being
there I did I did want to be there and I
tried to be there but unfortunately the
timing didn't work out I was working on
my movie at the exact same time that
they were filming the freak you man
freak you I think this way is clear I
can open this up at the exact same time
they were filming the FNAF movie so when
you know I was supposed to go out there
and they like I want to say to their
credit they tried to adjust the schedule
a couple times I feel like they could
have adjusted a little more but they
tried to adjust the schedule a couple
times and it just didn't line up because
it would have had me take
like two probably 3 days out of my own
filming schedule and my filming schedule
was so tight already that I couldn't
sacrifice one let alone three days it
would compromise the quality of iron
lung and I wasn't about to do that and I
would I wouldn't expect them to to
expect me to do that for them um just
like I wouldn't expect them to
compromise the quality of their movie
for me just to make room for me to be in
there that's it's not how I operate so I
don't expect it's how they operate
either
I don't like
this I want to check the camera but I
feel like I can't even look away from
this oh my God that's going to that's
going to get me if I don't press it
specifically okay well Freddy's over
there and I'm not dealing with that
that's awful okay oh wait but Freddy's
right there that means oh screw you man
screw you
I don't know do I open the
door oh my god oh well I'm still going
to die because I don't have enough power
God I cannot leave this one closed I I
keep doing that I can't leave it closed
what I have to do is I have
to I have to figure
out oh my God I have to figure
out how Freddy Works what his actual
mechanics are because I can't the crank
is by Pirates
Cove
oh
boy that light timing was not cool the
timing of my light was not
cool keeping both doors closed might
result in Freddy camping that's fair
okay so that tells me something that
tells me
something all right but let me let me
scope out what this crank
is and then I'm going to see what else
is going on so if that's by if that's by
Pirates Cove I know that there's got to
be something where I'm expected to get
outside it cannot be that I'm stuck in
the entire time so Pirates Cove said
there was a crank I don't see no crank I
see arcades please don't tell me it's up
on Foxy's stage that would be awful I'm
probably going to die this time don't
worry about it that's
fine not seeing a crank what do you mean
what do you mean a crank there's no
crank in
here I'm
doomed I'm doomed I don't see no
crank they lied they lied to
me they
lied they
lied okay what if I play this more like
what it's supposed to be which is free
roam Five Nights at Freddy's right so
I'm supposed to be able to use this
space fully unless
whoa unless Freddy just be
zooming all the
time
uh
uhhuh cuz that's what this meant to be
it's meant to be free roam and I don't
think free roam is meant to be played
camping
right so I can see down that
hallway oh my God I hate everything
about
that
what
what oh
oh
oh oh hi hi
foxy oh oh I can see I can see down
there chica is's down
there Ah that's how I can see down and
then technically this one can also see
down ah so chica's there as soon as
chica's gone I can open that
door why what is
happening it that
that makes
sense that makes sense that that made
sense that yeah apparently that was foxy
um good God this is difficult this is
difficult I got a lot left to
learn oh man all right
so let's try that again some people are
saying it's on foxy stage I don't
believe
you I don't believe you there's no crank
there's
nothing it's just
foxy there's no
nothing it's
nothing
so I don't know what you're talking
about but there ain't
nothing all right so what I could
do instead of just being in the office
is once I get a better layout of this
space I could keep an eye on
them whoa now oh God oh God please
please please
please
did I try the steam room what are you oh
hi what are you talking about what are
you yapping
about hi chica you going to come back
this way or you going to be a dick I
mean [__] you [__] you chica [__]
you oh this is
uncomfortable easy is
that hate
this there's a lot of hahaing going
on and I don't particularly enjoy
that one second
okay well oh God he looked at me is that
bad oh oh my God oh my God it's
fine I thought that was foxy
charging oh something's coming
that's not
good what was that is that
Freddy oh oh
oh oh what are you doing don't do it
don't do it don't do it bro bro bro bro
oh oh
no
oh
no I can't see down
there well foxy what do I
do who is
that Bonnie Bonnie hav't done anything
wrong Bonnie is innocent as the day he
was
oh ah is this sucking my power or
something
or what is this supposed to
do I mean I can't really suck my power
anymore because I'm just
like is Freddy there I I
don't
okay what am I supposed to
do stop it oh what did he just
die
what
I got
Bamboozled that can't be right how can
he bamboozle
me how can he bamboo
me
all right yeah
no that's not
fair that's not fair at
all I don't know what I'm supposed to do
about
that okay let's try that
again will iron lung be a fulllength
movie Yes it's qu I I love these
questions and I'm not trying to like
disparage you in any way but these these
questions that are always like but will
it be a movie and I'm like yeah but but
will it be like an in theater movie and
I go like yeah it'll be in theaters but
will it be full length I'm like yes yes
[__] yes yes
yeah so anyway yes it will be a full
movie enjoy the trailer and enjoy the
the further content coming about it as
it
comes it will be
glorious whether it's International I do
not know I cannot answer that question
yet yeah the main point that I wanted to
talk about here is that I'm home I won't
be in the FNAF movie Iron long is
getting exciting and also just like life
is returning to normal everything is
going wonderfully for me I was in Korea
recently for chusok I want to get back
in Korean learning I want to just get
back into a regular schedule of my life
you know I feel like for some reason
I've been able to like really adapt well
with all the chaos of everything like
despite my ADHD like I it kind of works
in that favor having to be frantic um
there's something that's like almost I
don't know having like a constantly
shifting uh kind of schedule in a weird
way is fun it keeps it
engaging and at least interesting
so that I'm always like trying something
new but there is something nice about
like getting back home just being able
to get on a regular schedule and being
able to get a routine going
again especially now that like I'm
actually able to get a steady supply of
the medication that I'm on that is nice
I know there's still like a shorter for
everyone else um and that's a whole
another story and a whole different
thing that I was wrestling with in the
midst of all that
nonsense but
thankfully atarus seems to finally have
worked out all the Kinks that I had a
year ago oh freak you and I'm able to
get my prescriptions filled
regularly and it is
nice and consistency is the key to
productivity or something like that I
don't know I don't know if that's true
though I don't know if
that's I don't know if that's true
because
sometimes I feel like
chaos is the greatest tool for
productivity that mankind has ever
experienced
okay you know what I
mean
who what did that mean about the flash
what W what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing Freddy what are
you doing Freddie
Freddy Freddy
no Freddy not like
this man I don't know what this AI is on
but it's on something
mean they programmed rude right into the
circuits that's not cool that's not fair
Freddy fast
bear I don't know I don't know man I
don't know look I'm just playing the
game at least I think I'm
him because the thing is I can't keep
track of Freddy on the camera enough to
predict when he's going to come at me
and also I don't even know if it matters
if I do that's why I kind of keep that
door closed is just because I don't know
when he's going to be coming to wreck my
[__] and it's not like I could have left
the office at that point he was in the
office and Foxy was at the other door so
I was like what was I supposed to do
there was nothing I
could
anyway the most I can do is just keep an
eye on foxy there all right that's
fun yeah let's just try that let's keep
an eye on foxy hit it every once in a
while okay well maybe not helpful at all
maybe I'm screwed no matter what I do
yeah I was kind of
screwed yeah for
sure I don't even know if sprinting
Health's in this small space I can't do
anything long enough
but I just really okay well that's
unfortunate okay so if he move where
does he move
too that's what I can't
tell he goes anywhere unless wellp never
mind oh no that's
Bonnie
okay oh crap cuz I know in the base
game thought I heard
something
oh
what
Freddy
Fazbear you Freddy Faz
[__] all right okay all
right is iron long self funded yes it is
yes it is that was yeah that was that
was sudden I see I wonder okay this is
what I'm starting to like piece together
about Freddy here is if he even spots
you on the camera he will come after you
so it almost is beneficial to not look
for him because if he sees he does lock
eyes with the camera and I don't know
that just feels like pretty soon after
that he comes after you so it's does
that mean I'm on the right track or what
you stupid light so it's almost like I
don't want to look for him cuz it's like
he looks and then he he kind of beines
straight for me right you know what I
mean I think that might be it so it's
like all I got to do is not see him and
I'll be okay everything else I think I
can just listen
for listen for his laughs and that's the
other thing yeah I do know the
laughs maybe if the laugh is like close
is that what I'm supposed to be looking
for
well there's a laugh I don't know if
that sounded
close
laugh that sounded rude that sounded
very rude I didn't like that one that
giggle has some T to it that
turle
the gar the gfar of
87 the T of
oh what wait that didn't make any sense
wait someone at my
door
I I don't
know
no well that doesn't sound
good laughs laughs laughs laugh it up
fast
[__] just keep
giggling okay so chica's right there
keep an
eye that sounded like the Laugh was
coming from over here but surely that
must not be
right
[__]
okay so if I can keep foxy under
control I'm all
right
Freddy can laugh all he
wants oh freck oh God I didn't look
enough I thought I could make
it well I have no idea how much power
of I hate this I hate this so much I
hate this so
much oh freak not
enough what was that was that something
was that something I can control
nope hi
Freddy that wasn't anybody at this door
though I don't think anyway I think that
was just Freddy zoom into the other
door okay never mind don't like
that what what okay well I'm doomed damn
it oh
hi oh you scar scared of me H are you
scared of me what
what try to keep distance from Freddy
being up close may result in death yeah
I've kind of discovered that on my own
yeah absolutely on my
own yeah good God okay so I'm I'm I'm
starting to piece together a strategy
here I think my problem there was that I
just needed to look at Foxy a bit more
and open up the other door more but it's
like It's tricky because Freddy really
likes to hang around that one door and I
don't know when he's going to be there
but even if I could open up just a
little
bit like that's that's kind of like what
I'm going for here is like slowly
opening it more and more so that I know
when my limits are but it's it's like
it's like
a it's like what else can I do Freddy's
so
fast I don't know if this fan helps
anyway now that I'm back if anybody has
any questions for me they could be about
you know iron lung they could be about
the fact that I'm not going to be in the
Five Nights at Freddy's movie that's
fine or it could just be about my life
and how I'm doing
wonderfully just feel free to ask right
now oh I need to look at
foxy foxy oh that was terrible I hated
that when people say it's pre-recorded I
don't know who would say that it's a
live stream why would I go through the
trouble of pre-recording a live stream
why wouldn't I just post a
video
yep am I okay man yeah I am I know it's
been absent from videos um and I know
the last time I talked about you know
not being able to do both at once was a
factor of like not being able to get
medication for a while for ADHD for
those you who don't know I have ADHD and
I uh take a stars for it um and it's not
necessarily there was a shortage of
other ADHD medications but this one
actually is in stock and is a recent one
that I'm changed over to but yada y y
it's still new so it was difficult um
that is not the case for this particular
string of issues that I've had it is
moreover
been largely that there the sheer amount
of work that needed to be done to get up
to like this deadline that I had on
Friday was significantly higher than I
expected it to
be oh oh close damn
you
oh oh
oh oh and therefore I just had to put in
significantly more effort than I had
previously thought into the amount of
editing that I had to do for iron
lung and so now that I'm back
yeah AGD meds have been out yeah there
has been like this shortage this
Nationwide shortage um but starus is in
stock and that has been very helpful for
me um and getting [__] done for those
that are properly prescribed it this is
who I'm talking to not anyone else yeah
fre oh [__] [__] you distracted me you
distracted
me why would you do that
why would you do that why would you guys
do
that why would
you why would you guys do
that I know I know I don't know what
that's
doing maybe this is obscuring any other
sound I can
hear how do the meds help me well I mean
okay so I'm not a neuroscientist right
and this is a hell of a time to try to
answer this question but I'm going to do
it anyway cuz I'm just that good
um or I'm
not
what the freak was
that what was
that why would you be singing that
song oh oh what this doesn't make any
sense
what
what why would you be doing that song
now there's someone at that door I can
see the
eye okay I don't think there's anyone at
this door
though
okay so how does it help me okay so this
is the
thing but this particular
medication all of
them
are either a dopamine reuptake inhibitor
or a
dopamine I think the word is
Agonist it
either pushes open
or slows the reuptake of it so you have
more in your system and this one in
particular is we have
taken but the benefit
is I can actually sleep with it which is
great
and it still creates a very it's it's
mechanism of
release is based on your body's
ability to metabolize the medication
Therefore your body has a very
consistent Supply throughout the entire
day
do I like
it doesn't have doesn't have a peek in a
crash keeps a
very a very even
experience oh
freak
what
what what are you doing toim me Freddy
what are you
doing is that why it played the song
beforehand dude you can't do
that I don't even know what time it was
I I
don't run when the power's out what do
you mean run where would I
go where would I
go there is nowhere to
go unless I can find a way to just clip
out of the level can I get into the back
rooms here can I just
please what I'm
craving
this guy really dislikes me he does not
enjoy my presence he does not enjoy my
existence does not enjoy anything about
me and he
wishes that I was dead ah so there
probably some new people that have
joined since the last time I am afraid
that I have the disappointing news of
the fact that I am not going to be in
the Five Nights at Freddy's movie
unfortunately schedules did not line
up don't ask don't ask what my Magic
Touch
is I don't care if there's a key to
anything I'm not I'm not going for it
it's not the strategy I'm employing at
the
moment just trying to keep foxy under
control that's it
no oh
tricks the longer I can keep these doors
open oh
why
how is that
fair
fair see that's what I don't understand
is what is Freddy's
mechanics what is Freddy's
mechanics I I know for those of you who
are outraged and screaming
um it's it's a fact that that I was too
busy with iron lung to make it to be in
and iron yes iron lung's going to be in
theaters it's it just the schedules did
not line up I know that this is
disappointing I'm going to give this
like one or two more tries I don't know
if I'm going to be able to get this
because Freddy just just ruins my
existence unless there's something about
like the line of sight okay this could
be it where because I'm peeking through
the door in a very specific way it could
be that technically speaking okay so if
I'm looking through here he could
technically be right there and then he
thinks I can see him but I
can't even though like by all accounts
you know I can't see him he might not
believe that oh that's great I can reach
that from there that's awesome can I
reach that from there no why why why is
this button have to be that close that's
unfair but I can be that far away from
that that's
unfair that's what you would call unfair
and this light is so haunted but that's
the only thing that I could see is that
there would be some Lin of sight thing
Freddy would be like oh he's looking at
me and then he would gun right at
me have I gotten my high quality Moon
picture yeah I've gotten plenty of high
quality Moon pictures not a print yet
but I have received
many he really wants
stop okay does that mean that he's
nearby I really wish I
knew oh
God I hate it I'm just I just want to
close it so I can
check at least with like a modum of
safety
I don't
know oh God okay well just just let me
die what was that I don't even
know I don't even
know
oh God what no that's not right he
doesn't spring to that door he just
doesn't and I don't know if he's over
there I would love to be able to open
that door I don't see wait I do there's
something
there I
think he's not
happy I'm trying
it oh
okay
sure he's doing the music why would he
do that why would he do that he can't do
that it leaves no time for me to be
me
Wait no that's a different music wait
that's different that was different
music no that was different music
okay Freddy's a real son of a [__] okay
I'm going to open it all
right I think it might have been a line
I
okay 37% 4: a.m. that's not
terrible oh my oh my God oh my
God oh my
God yeah me and Ethan are still friends
that was all a
joke oh my God
okay pretty
good all
right haven't seen the
others oh God hated that dum dum don't
call me
Dum doing good doing good doing good I
I'm going to keep that other door down
just because I think I have enough power
to last through
there might be final words but I think I
do yeah I think I do I
do
that was a chica poster I thought I saw
her oh maybe not maybe I don't maybe I
don't maybe this is a horrible error
this might be a horrible error this
might be a terrible terrible mistake
that I making this might be the worst
mistake I've ever made this might be
awful in uh an unbelievable way oh God I
might be
[__] I might have boned myself super
hard
I don't think I'm going to make
it it was a terrible oh
no
what I'll take
it I'll take it
baby he realized he skipped the other
one and he gave me a
freebie he gave me a
freebie
all
right well there you have
it I want it because I am the
king uh because I have unbelievable luck
sometimes and unbelievably terrible luck
sometimes Freddy knows who's the boss is
and even if I'm not going to be in the
iron movie If I'm not
the even if I'm not in the Five Nights
Freddy's movie doesn't mean that I still
don't know what I'm doing anyway that
was just night four there's still night
five um I'll get that eventually but
thank you so much for watching thank you
so much for your patience uh your
wailing of nashing and nashing of teeth
has been noted um but look forward to
iron long if you haven't checked out the
trailer check it out share with a friend
I think it's a pretty cool trailer and I
think it gives a real nice taste of what
the movie is going to be like so thank
you thank you so much for watching uh
thank you for all your patience we are
coming back to regularly scheduled
videos coming soon lots of fun stuff on
the way and uh more exciting things to
come many more lots of uh payoff for all
the work that has been occurring yes
thank you have a lovely day um again
whale and the national of teeth all that
you want to take here have a nice one
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye bye guys bye farewell
goodbye and goodbye and
farewell and also bye